President Trump says school shootings
will be on the top of his agenda when he
meets with a group of Governors the
president hosted a dinner for the
governors last night they'll discuss a
series of proposals today including a
higher age limit to buy firearms and
stronger background checks major Garrett
is at the White House major good morning
well good morning as you mentioned the
president welcomed the nation's
governor's here to the White House last
night and singled out Rick Scott
Florida's Republican governor and
possible US Senate candidate later this
year for his leadership after the
parklands shooting the governor has been
working with the legislature in Florida
on school safety he and the president
though don't always agree on future gun
control we'll be talking about parkland
and the horrible event that took place
last week President Trump told the
nation's governor's he's still working
on a school safety agenda Saturday night
mr. Trump again called for arming
teachers we would have had some great
teachers that were gonna adept you
wouldn't have this problem the
president's daughter said during a visit
to the Olympics in South Korea that idea
was worth discussing having a teacher
who is armed who cares deeply about her
students or his students and who is
capable and qualified to bear arms is
not a bad idea Rick Scott Florida's
Republican governor disagreed with the
president
I want our teachers to teach and I want
and I want our law enforcement officers
to be able to protect the students Scott
like the president supported raising the
federal minimum age for long gun sales
to 21 the alleged parkland assailant 19
year-old Nicholas Cruz used a legally
purchased ar-15 semiautomatic rifle
doesn't seem to make sense that you have
to wait till you're 21 years old to get
a pistol but to get a gun like this
maniac used in the school you get that
at 18 the National Rifle Association
opposes raising the minimum age for
firearms purchases and a spokeswoman
yesterday suggested President Trump
agrees Congress is back in town to see
where gun legislation fits in a already
crowded legislative agenda focused on
immigration and the
the president will meet with Republicans
here at the White House tomorrow John
okay major thanks